a local hospital is holding a raffle as
a fundraiser the individual cost of
participating in the raffle is given by
the following expression 5t plus 3 or 5
times t plus 3 where t represents the
number of tickets someone purchases
evaluate the expression when t is equal
to 1 T is equal to 8 and T is equal to
10 so let's first take the situation
where t where t is equal to 1 then this
expression right over here becomes and
I'll use that same color it becomes 5
times 1 5 times 1 plus 3 5 times 1 plus
3 and we know from order of operations
you do the multiplication before you do
the addition so this will be 5 times 1
is 5 plus 3 and then this is clearly
equal to this is equal to 8 now let's do
it when T is equal to 8 so when t is
equal to 8 when T is equal to 8 this
expression becomes and I'll do the same
colors again 5 times 8 5 times 8 plus 3
plus 3 same color of green plus 3 and
once again 5 times 8 is 40 40 and then
we have the plus 3 there so this is
equal to 43 and so we have the last
situation with T is equal to 10 I'll do
that in blue I'll do that in blue so we
have 5 times 10 so 5 T is 5 times 10
instead of a T we put a 10 there 5 times
10 plus 3 plus 3 that's a slightly
different shade of green whether you get
the idea 5 times 10 is 50 we do 50 and
then we're gonna have to add 3 to that
and that is equal to 53 and we're done